y sentimos
[Música]
está la apariencia que algunas mujeres
sueñan con tener los famosos glúteos de
kim kardashian desde que se hizo famosa
en 2007 la silueta de esta estrella
internacional ha inspirado a muchas
mujeres en las redes sociales aunque la
estrella asegura que sus curvas son
naturales muchos médicos dicen que
algunas mujeres sueñan con tener una
silueta similar y por eso recurren a una
cirugía plástica en particular que se
llama el brazilian butt lift o
levantamiento brasileño de glúteos en
este tipo de cirugía la grasa es
extraída de varias partes del cuerpo y
luego es inyectada en los glúteos
esta operación aparentemente sencilla
puede tener graves consecuencias para la
salud
nuestra observadora geli larsson se
sometió a un levantamiento brasileño en
2009 en la ciudad de miami y desde
entonces advierte a otras mujeres sobre
los peligros de esta cirugía estética
antes de este look eres realmente algo
misterioso inalcanzable que tenían las
kardashians y otras celebridades
saber y presentar a naves
y ahora cada vez que bajas en tu página
explorar ves personas de 20 años o
incluso de 18 o 19 años y tuvieron los
medios para costearse este tipo de
operación y cada vez es más frecuente
1 de cada 3 mil pacientes muere no es
que uno de cada tres mil tenga
complicaciones sino que uno de cada tres
mil pacientes muere y
empezó a darme cuenta de que había
problemas hasta el día de mi operación
y no tenía la fuerza para retractarme ni
la voluntad de perder todo ese dinero es
muy invasivo es una varilla de metal que
te apuñala por dentro y te empuja la
piel
la recuperación del levantamiento
brasileño fue una de las peores cosas
que he experimentado en cuanto a dolor
se refiere a adiós bergman
bien recuerdo que estaba muy enfadada
conmigo misma por someterme a tanto
dolor por la apariencia física
geli larsson pagó diez mil dólares por
su operación no le ocurrió nada grave
pero aún así tuvo dolores corporales
durante un año y dice haber quedado muy
decepcionada con los
a diferencia de larsson muchas mujeres
van a países como república dominicana
méxico o turquía donde la cirugía es
menos costosa pero los cirujanos no
están calificados y hay pocos cuidados
postoperatorios
para mí es importante hablar de los
peligros y la realidad de los
levantamientos brasileños porque si
alguien me hubiera contado estas cosas
auguró habría tenido expectativas más
realistas los levantamientos brasileños
no te dan un cuerpo de instagram porque
los cuerpos de instagram no existen
instagram me hizo querer cambiar mi
cuerpo me hizo sentirme mal conmigo
misma y compararme todo el día con las
imágenes retocadas en internet
el efecto levantamiento brasileño nos
afectó a todos
creo que ha afectado la percepción de
los hombres sobre el cuerpo de las
mujeres
y también la percepción de las mujeres
sobre su propio cuerpo
ahora los hombres esperan un nivel de
perfección que no existe y las mujeres
esperan lo mismo de ellas
los especialistas calculan que cada año
son realizadas 500.000 operaciones este
tipo y que una de cada tres mil
pacientes muere en este procedimiento
esto la convierte en la cirugía estética
más mortal del mundo
ya sea a través de su posición con
alguien cara a cara tienen que hacerlo y
mauri son innata y trabaja como
consultor para empresas se utiliza tick
tock para enseñar el terreo maorí que es
la lengua indígena de los maoríes de
nueva zelanda son y forma parte de una
comunidad que cada vez es más numerosa y
que utiliza las redes sociales para
promover la lengua y la cultura de este
pueblo ancestral
cría que la gente se hiciera una idea de
lo que se siente poder hablar la lengua
nativa de otear o nueva zelanda pero
quieren saber cómo firmar sus correos
electrónicos entere o maorí les digo con
mal e igual hasta pronto
[Música]
también creé este canal porque soy un
firme defensor de la revitalización del
toreo maorí amor y creo que uno de los
elementos clave en la revitalización de
una lengua es que se pronunció
correctamente
en nombre del lugar maorí o bien
escuchar mal pronunciado empiezo yo
se pronuncia para para un no sé de dónde
viene el para para am el terreo maorí
comenzó a desaparecer en el siglo 19 con
la creciente llegada de colonos ingleses
a nueva zelanda en la década de 1980 la
lengua estaba prácticamente al borde de
la extinción pero los hablantes lucharon
arduamente por su supervivencia
d
tengo mucha suerte porque estoy
recogiendo los frutos del trabajo
realizado por quienes lucharon por la
lengua hace muchos años
sabían qué rotorúa significa segundo
lago yo les digo porque
a medida que nos hacemos más conscientes
de lo que significa hacer neozelandeses
y de lo que significa vivir aquí en
outeiro a nueva zelanda
nos vamos dando cuenta de que para
entender nuestro país su belleza y sus
maravillas
también tenemos que entender la lengua
autóctona
creo que los medios holandeses son cada
vez más conscientes de esto
en la actualidad alrededor del 25 por
ciento de la población maorí de nueva
zelanda habla el terreno maorí a nivel
intermedio sólo el 9% lo habla con
fluidez y en la población no maorí de
nueva zelanda sólo el 1% de estas
personas se puede comunicar en este
idioma
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si desean
entrar en contacto con la producción del
programa los datos para comunicarse
aparecer en sus pantallas tal vez usted
puede hacer parte de nuestra red global
de observadores hasta pronto